the Word of God is the gateway to the
world of welcome shows that the church
counts money lots of money it's
collecting more than half a million
dollars a week
Louisiana televangelist is asking his
followers for donations to buy a fifty
four million dollar private jet what if
I told you that you could start a
business that was exempt from paying any
federal state local or property taxes
your customers treated you like holy
divinity and showered you a cash every
time you walked into the room
your customers will will only pay for
you to live in multi-million dollar
homes tax-free and you're in a position
where you're able to openly ask your
customers to pay for fifty four million
dollar private jets so that you can
travel the world in comfort without
having to put up with a petri dish that
is commercial airliners will get your
Bibles out loosen up those morals
because this is how to be a preacher
profiteer
[Music]
being a preacher profiteer is just like
any other business it helps if you
understand your customers and your
market and much like the business of war
the business of religion is as primal as
it gets since the days of our ancestors
fearing mother nature fearing and
believing in a higher power has been
part of what makes humans human and
whether you're religious or not you and
the other almost 8 billion people or
shall I say customers on this planet
have this emotion this primal instinct
of divinity and as the famous historian
and philosopher well Durant puts it the
function of religion is quite different
it is to give man a belief to tolerate
life to enable man to bear reality this
is the business were in we're not
selling sermons we're not selling church
choirs no no no we're in the business of
selling hope selling salvation selling
community selling the ability to
tolerate the difficulties of life and
when you're viewed as the benevolent
authority on hope the afterlife
salvation your customers are gonna take
you pretty seriously in fact it's pretty
safe to say that the customers of
religion on the most enthusiastic
customers of any industry the Bishop
lives in wealth our hidden cameras
documented that when Bishop Bailey
enters a church members crowd the aisles
to press cash money into his hands he
reaches out to pick the green bills see
in business the more dire than need the
more people are willing to pay you may
not be willing to pay 850 thousand
dollars for a glorified a watch but what
about for a cancer treatment or a
potential cure for blindness that is the
power of religion not only is this so
deep in the human condition but you get
the cell to society's most vulnerable
people with the most dire needs all
you've got is a thousand dollars listen
that's not enough money anyway to buy
the house you're trying to get in the
apartment you just wander by the
that's not enough money anyway you get
to that phone and you put that seed in
the ground and watch God work it out
take Bonnie Parker for example who was
an avid believer of the very big
televangelist Kenneth and Gloria
Copeland the Copeland's along with other
televangelist preached the concept of
the prosperity gospel the idea that the
more you donate or the bigger the seed
you so the more prosperity and the more
blessings you'll get back so when Bonnie
Parker got cancer
why go get cancer treatment what you can
just donate all your money to the church
after all the more you donate the higher
the chance you'll get healed but the
benefits don't stop there because you're
protected by the government for all the
other plebs out there the IRS may seem
like your worst enemy but the churches
they're your guardian angel because of
that great little clause in the US
Constitution that says freedom of
religion or whatever the IRS has always
taken a very hands-off approach to
overseeing and regulating churches an
approach that are not well known for
that means the business of religion puts
the greatest tax havens on earth like
the Cayman Islands to shame no plebeian
federal state local or property taxes
you don't have to worry about that pesky
FTC looking into your sketchy business
practices like they most definitely
would if those same practices or even
much less sketchy practices would use in
any other business and you also get
other very nice perks unheard of
anywhere else with my favorite being the
parsonage allowance which basically
means that you can be paid a certain
amount of money every year from your
church as a housing allowance that's not
too special the special part is that not
only is that income not tax but there's
no cap to it since the housing allowance
is only limited by the fair rental
market value of the house you can live
in any size house your heart desires and
not pay any taxes the bigger the house
the bigger the tax break because the
parsonage allowance is limited only by
the fair market rental value of the
pastor's home now I know you're thinking
the only logical path forward is to
become a preacher profiteer but how what
are the actual steps that you can take
to make money
name of whatever God you choose first
and foremost we can't sell religion if
we don't have a religion now being that
the IRS is intentionally vague with a
definition of what qualifies as a church
we have a lot of wiggle room to work
with but I urge you don't go all out
Flying Spaghetti Monster religion on me
because here's the thing the name of the
game is making money so we want to stay
on the safe side so if you go with a
more mainstream religion like
Christianity people have already
accepted it's a thing and you'll have
less of a wall to break through to get
people through the doors to open their
hearts to you and most importantly to
open their wallets to you Christianity
Catholicism Mormonism all are fair game
just take your pick it could be a
miracle it could be booked there's only
one thing we know for sure it's a
goddamn gold mine now picking the
religion or the specific sect is the
easy part
the hard part is actually delivering
getting people through the door and
getting them to come back and getting
them to bring their friends people
generally go to church for the same
reasons something is lacking in their
life and they believe church might fill
it maybe less a sense of community maybe
they're looking for answers maybe
they're looking for hope
motivation is someone to guide them
through the troubles of life to know
that they're not alone maybe it's the
penance for their sins these are the
emotions and deep rooted pain points
that we need to go after the worst thing
that you can do is let people leave
Church feeling yeah
people have to be lifted love and her
dress and brought together by the end of
every session or else they won't come
back or in other words you have to
ignite the emotion of divinity that we
all have within us the stronger the
emotions you elicit the more success in
the more contributions you'll have see
in this line of work you're not a
preacher you're not a pastor you're a
divine motivational speaker the leader
that the disciples will gladly follow to
the ends of the
earth the man with all the answers
anything less and how her whole scheme
falls apart you have to be a master of
emotions get this right and everything
else will follow
your customers will look at you as a
demigod people will keep coming back
they'll bring their friends the size of
your congregation will continuously grow
you'll have the money to open new
locations fund new projects a marketing
returns will start to compound over each
other and of course the size of your
church donations will follow suit and if
you're a really charismatic leader
you'll get to experience the same
blessings as other preacher prophet
seers your disciples will shower you a
cash when you enter the room
sweet daddy Bailey travels with a
uniformed entourage arrives on a throne
and a parade in Washington DC each
Memorial Day you can assure customers to
fund your private jet collection and the
majority of them won't even bat an eye
parishioner Mary Jones who takes the bus
to church says she'd happily give $2 jet
drive most definitely most definitely we
support our pastor that's what we're
here for because in their mind they're
not giving you money they're giving the
Lord money to spread his message which
brings us to the next step in our divine
journey now church donations can be very
profitable but why stop there our entire
journey has been building up to this
points you have the audience the
personal brand the influence now it's
time to monetize baby publish books get
paid to speak sell information products
collaborate what other mega churches
have that glorious housing allowance
that we talked about get on TV like the
other televangelists because we all know
that that is where the real money is at
now said mom I can't explain it but ever
since I planted a thousand dollar seed
I enjoy getting these checks via FedEx
even though typically these other
business ventures will be taxed is still
very lucrative and you'll always have
your church donations to fall back on
and to use as funding for these projects
so enjoy raking in that dough but don't
enjoy it too much because next up it's
time to protect the wealth that we
rightfully earned it's usually at the
monetization stage that many preacher
profit ears will start to run into some
friction with those pesky non-believers
those are criticizing how much money you
make your business practices and your
greed so we have to do everything in our
power to protect ourselves and our
business the number one thing you have
to do at all costs is hide your wealth
do not flaunt around and try to show off
it will only build animosity and don't
get me wrong get the million dollar
house with the housing allowance and
enjoy yourself but build a house in the
middle of the woods so it's hidden from
public view obscure your house and other
real estate holdings inside trust and
corporate entity side your name is not
on any of them have all your churchgoers
and employees sign a very strict NDA
saying that if they disclose any of the
church's finances you'll sue them have
measures in place that make your church
look transparent but never give away any
of the important financial numbers like
how much money you take home always
always set aside a portion of your
revenue to donate to good causes for
that sweetpea are a portion that will
make the average person think you are
Savior but you know that you're taking
home much more than that and at the end
of the day you have to remember you can
have all the money in the world but if
the general public despises you they'll
eventually take you down just look at
Martin shrilly so protect yourself and
welcome to the leak Club of preacher
profit ears get all riled up about this
scam or that scam that's all big scam
okay I will say this the church is
scammed it's a pretty good one it's
effective look at all the money these
people are giving to the church